[Musique]
alors j'en ai parlé avec certains chez
vous avez beaucoup beaucoup de choses à
dire sur ça et elle eu raison de quitter
tmp mais avant d'en parler on va
regarder un petit récapitulatif des
cette année d'enora dans cette émission
garde tous les amis voilà je vous fais
ces petites vidéos vous annoncer quelque
chose d'important à la grèce à 36 ans
enora malagré était l'une des
chroniqueuses emblématique de tp mpc
temps qu'elle animé avec ferveur les
débats déjà bec de ses coups de gueule
là ont nettement j'étais agacé devant ma
télé et ses coups de coeur jésus très
touchant et de cette annonce
innombrables elle était sans doute
l'atout charme de l'émission dans la
bande
elle était à la fois la bonne copine la
petite soeur une personnalité haute en
couleurs
c'est une des meilleures si ce n'est la
meilleure chroniqueuse en ce moment en
télé et jeux franchement mais depuis
quelques mois
enora était en plein doute sur son
avenir j'ai pas complètement pour que je
continue à faire ce que je fais là
tout ce que j'ai vécu ici ça fait un
moment que ça me travaille mais là je me
suis dit mais est-ce que j'ai pas perdu
mon temps moi donc je fais pas je sais
pas je sais pas sûr bon endroit mais
hier il n'aura annoncé son départ le jeu
vous annoncer ce soir que je vais
quitter je quittais
officiellement touche pas à mon poste il
est temps pour moi de partir après sept
années de fidélité
la jolie blonde par mais une chose est
sûre les souvenirs restent
voix
alors alors pas décédée c'est vraiment
parce que les chats qui nous la fait ça
j'avais pas vu le magnéto sur la tête de
ma mère on dirait qu'on l'a perdu doké
n'aura va bien voilà je vous le dit
laura va très bien